mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
a rectangle has a side length equal to
10.
construct two semi-circles as shown
where each semi-circle has a diameter
equal to the side length of the
rectangle
inscribe a circle in the rectangle
that's tangent to the two sides whose
lengths are equal to 10
and goes through the two intersection
points of the two semicircles
the question is what is the area of the
region
that's overlapping between the two
semi-circles
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
since the side length of the rectangle
is equal to 10
each of the semi-circles will have a
radius that's equal to 5.
now construct a radius between the
center of the semicircle
and one of the intersection points do
the same thing for the other
intersection point
each of these radii will have a length
equal to 5.
now consider the inscribed circle
we will construct a diameter of this
inscribed circle
since this is a diameter of the
inscribed circle
we must have the angle that's inscribed
opposite
will be a 90 degree angle thus we have a
right
triangle where two of its legs are equal
to five
we will now be able to calculate the
required area
notice this shape is a sector of the
semicircle
and it has a central angle equal to 90
degrees
thus its area will be equal to one
quarter that
of the entire circle so its area will be
equal
to pi r squared all over four and here r
is equal to five so we have pi
multiplied by 5 squared all over 4.
we will then subtract the area of this
right triangle
where 2 of its legs are equal to 5. the
area of this right triangle is equal to
5 times 5 all over 2.
the result will be equal to this shape
which is one half
of the area that we want to calculate
we'll write this out
then to get the entire area of the
overlapping region
we need to double this area so we add
this area to itself
and we get exactly the area of the shape
that we want
this simplifies to be 12.5 pi minus 25
which is approximately equal to 14.27
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time
you